pam is with us in cincinnati hi pam
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave thanks so much for taking my
call my honor how can we help
well i am 60 years old i'm a teacher
i cannot officially retire until i'm 65
but this school year right about a week
before the school year started
i was advised by my health care
professional that i should not return to
the school due to the covet situation
and some underlying issues that i have
i'm able to work i would work in five
jobs i work a retail job on the side i
do copy editing it on the side i do a
lot of stuff
on the side but um with this big chunk
of
income gone my husband who also works
wanted to take a loan out on his um
thrift savings plan he was in a
government thing
and i don't i desperately don't want him
to do that made that mistake years and
years ago
and i i i'm on board with you but i
don't have another
option and that the thing is there's a
lot of things i can just ramp up like my
copy editing business and stuff but
those will take a little bit of time
to build he's just well he's just
panicking
he's very scared absolutely so what does
he make
um he makes about well i can tell you
so he makes about 45 a year and you all
can't live
and well not with the house that we have
at this point and we haven't
a lot of debt okay and um
what do you have what is the debt
we've got credit card student loans and
another big loan that we had taken out
what is the other big one i think it was
we
desperately had to do some house repair
things don't have any car payments
well we have six thousand dollars left
on my car okay
all right what do you owe on your home
we
owe about um 205
000. and what can you make with what
you're with your situation right now
well i mean i really think i can ramp it
up and make as much i mean i figured out
mathematically that i only need to bring
in 30 000
a year for us to be okay and not just
you know so and that's with paying down
debt and getting
moving forward but the problem is just
this month like these next couple of
months where
i where the everything's not i haven't
built up
everything we don't just we just know
how to navigate
those couple months i thought about
doing door dash um
i mean because i'm a scrapper i'll do
whatever i have to do
so it's not okay to be in the classroom
but it's okay to do door dash
yeah well the the environment of the
school because schools are notoriously
not well ventilated i teach choir and so
the singing and the arab souls in a room
and it's a crowded environment that's
what he was most concerned about
it that doordash probably isn't well see
i'm not really in contact with anybody
that's what i'm thinking okay
i don't care well i mean can your
husband can your husband pick up some
extra
see all we got to do is do this for uh
60 or 90 days until your other stuff
kicks in right
right yeah well yeah until i get the
other stuff built up
and he already does he he works all the
overtime he can right now at his present
job
and that pretty much whips his butt
because he's working every day of the
week
and that's that nets him 40 grand after
overtime and everything
um no i think with the overtime now that
he's doing that that'll probably bring
us in some more than that yeah
yeah so because now he's bringing home
about 15 000
twice a week or next thousand fifteen
hundred twice a week
yeah yeah
i'm looking at extra jobs especially for
the next 60 to 90 days
um i'm with you i like the door dash um
i also like maybe even doing some uber
ubereats but let me ask you the other
question what can you do
as far as in a small business from home
to generate some income
yeah you're a music teacher yeah once
you start doing piano lessons or
something
yeah i do already i already do lessons
and i that's one of the things i can
build up see i didn't have a
to do a lot because i was busy teaching
school and yeah but
the kids bunch of them aren't going back
to school so they could probably
you could probably add some kids on
piano easier than you could add doordash
yeah right and that's true and it's just
going to take time to build that up
is the thing not much that doesn't
happen not not much and
i'll tell you this much i had a vocal
coach not for singing but for speaking
and she did that online
and so maybe you can take your your
opportunities online and generate money
and there are websites out there
that you can actually put your
information on and they will
they will actually push you out there
some more so you have some options here
to
go ahead and get some extra income
without uh touching the tsb
yeah i'm not touching it i'm gonna make
it yeah i would rather get behind on a
couple of bills than borrow
on the tsp and i don't think you're
going to have to
because i think some tight budgeting
lots of ingenuity on extra job things
for you and hubby the
over time he's already working and you
guys tighten this budget down tighten
this budget down tighten this budget
down cut the cable off all that kind of
crap
and let's just go to work and then and
then as you get your income up from some
of these different areas you may end up
making more than you did in the
classroom
when it's all over and um sadly they may
have lost a really good teacher
in the process that's really sad i'm
sorry you guys are facing this but
you're a scrapper i can tell by talking
to you and i think you're going to make
it she's going to do just fine
she's going to do perfect